bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
france 24 c'est un témoignage hors du
commun que nous recevons celui d'une
femme officier qui a rejoint la mission
de maintien de la paix quelques mois en
syrie en 2012 on est au tout début du
conflit kofi annan à la tête de l'onu
arrive à arracher un exploit un cessez
le feu 300 personnes que l'on nomme les
observateurs vont se rendre sur le
terrain ils ne portent pas d'armes c'est
une obligation et vont parler à toutes
les parties du conflit côtoyer la
population avide de révolution
incroyable quand on se retourne sur ce
qu'est la syrie dix ans plus tard un
pays ravagé par la guerre civile dévoré
par les exactions des terroristes
bombardé par toutes les plus grandes
puissances du monde cinq cent mille
morts la moitié de sa population obligée
de fuir soit 20 millions de personnes
réfugiées et n'aura jamais bonjour merci
d'être allé à france 24 pour nous parler
de ce livre quand s'avance l'ombre où
vous raconter une mission assez j'allais
dire atypique qui est une mission de
maintien de la paix dans le cadre de
l'onu est ce que vous nous définir ce
qu'a été cette mission de maintien de la
paix techniques manquent qu'est ce que
c'est lent techniquement vous avez qui
est un peu particulier on reviendra
dessus mais techniquement en général une
mission de maintien de la paix est
décidée par le conseil de sécurité qui
décide que dans le cadre d'un conflit ou
naissant ou en cours on va envoyer des
missions d'observateurs en général armés
au moins minima pour se protéger
pour rassurer les parties et pour
observer que les accords de cessez le
feu les faits et tout un tas d'indicés
qui sont définies par le conseil de
sécurité sont respectées alors dans
cette mission là vous n'êtes pas armé et
quelle est votre mission alors on n'est
pas armé parce que
l'onu est capable de faire que ce qu'on
lui permet de faire et en l'occurrence
lorsque le conseil de sécurité a accepté
dans un tout petit créneau possible de
nous projeter les russes n'ont permis
que très peu de choses et on était donc
désarmée on était donc observateurs et
notre mission était bien d'observer que
les points qui avaient été définis comme
ça comme garant du cessez-le-feu était
respecté par les deux parties ça veut
dire que vous allez allez parler avec
toutes les parties qui sont sur le
théâtre du conflit avec toutes les
parties sachant conneries qu'on ne
connaissait pas et c'était une partie
c'était un volet de la mission qui est l
armée syrienne libre qui étaient les
rebelles et ce qu'ils étaient en train
de se solidifier ce qu'ils étaient
coordonnés personne ne connaissait à
l'époque ces acteurs et ça faisait aussi
partie de la mission dont parlait à tout
le monde et puis découvrir ce que l'un
des acteurs souhaitait alors j'ai déjà
posé qu'à une chose c'est que sur le
livre il ya marqué qu une femme officier
de renseignement raconte j'insistais
parce que vous disiez par mémé vous
restez militaire et vous êtes officier
de renseignement qu'on vous allez sur
place c'est à dire qu'est ce que vous
êtes un espion ah non non mais alors
déjà militaire oui parce que c'est sur
un théâtre de guerre donc il est certain
qu'un diplomate aurait certainement eu
mieux sa place mais il n'aurait
peut-être pas vécu longtemps et puis
c'est des choses peu terre à terre
auprès des jambons donc militaire
absolument art mais bon on n'a pas été
et ce qui a normalement on laisse au
moins les gens est rare mais de façon à
s'auto défendre là ce n'était pas le cas
et vous dites finalement c'est pas si
mal et finalement c'est mieux c'était
passé mal c'est sans doute ce qui nous a
sauvé la vie qui a permis que tout le
monde revienne en vie parce que d'abord
on aura fait une bêtise dans l'état de
stress dans lequel on était
et puis qu'est ce qu'on aurait fait avec
une arme pour inverser le cours des
choses et puis une arme c'est toujours
un peu compliqué de parler aux gens
lorsque vous êtes lorsque vous êtes armé
et vu l'a vu la sensibilité la brutalité
finalement c'était ce qui nous a sauvés
c'est de parler à tout le monde
justement alors peut-être renseignement
alors elle en rend secrètement pas
espionne un officier de renseignement
c'est quelqu'un dont le métier consiste
à détecter
puis à analyser à exploiter on va dire
tous tous les signes qui peuvent qui ont
trait à la sécurité d'un pays de son
pays ou à ses intérêts donc là
évidemment ce n'était pas la sécurité
d'un pays c'était la communauté
internationale et les méthodes qui
s'applique un officier de renseignement
en france ou ailleurs dans l'otan en
fait on va dire était tout à fait
transposable là bas donc on avait
effectivement un oeil d'un peu
d'officiels renseignement par contre
pourquoi pas espions parce que alors
office de renseignement s'est pas bureau
des légendes c'est un autre métier très
respectable et très impressionnant mais
pas le nôtre nous nous étions à la vue
de tous un espion il il se renseigne en
cachette sur une personne déterminée
nous toute personne n'ignorait notre
mission personnes ignoraient où l'on se
trouvait ce que l'on voyait ce dont on
rend des comptes alors votre livre est
très très bien écrit je dois avouer que
il se dit vraiment ligne par ligne c'est
un journal et on se rend compte la
difficulté que vous avez quand vous
allez dans ce pays il yad'abord bachar
al assad forcément on se demande quel
rôle il va jouer c'était aussi votre
question oui c'était surtout la question
des syriens en fait au moment où on
arrive donc en avril avril mais un 2012
beaucoup de certains se demandent
beaucoup c'est bien pensé espère
peut-être qu'il est mal conseillé il a
mal compris le problème il est mal
conseillé c'est quelqu'un
d'occidentaliser qui a toujours une
bonne réputation de don patillo douceur
de caractère et donc la population
syrienne se dit mais ce tome elle est
sûrement mal conseillé ccc ses proches
qui sont violents ce sont les services
qui sont violents et d'ailleurs vous
avez beaucoup de rebelles qui nous
disent je ne sais pas pas sharks on veut
éliminer on dépasse situation irakienne
ou libanaise ce qu'on veut éliminer ces
les services de renseignements qui sont
très effrayant et puis alors un syrien
m'a dit moi je n'ai pas identifié dans
le livre un serial m'a dit que la
première fêlure les questions qui se
posent c'est au moment de la massacrer
ou la du village de houla où là on a vu
effectivement les syriens pro bachar
regarder la télévision regarde le
porte-parole marc tessier expliqué que
ce n'était pas une exaction du
gouvernement et on a vu les syriens qui
espérait vraiment que c'était vrai vous
dans votre livre vous racontez que vous
êtes arabophone vous parler la langue
vous êtes plusieurs fois les en syrie
vous connaissez le pays c'est pour ça
que vous allez sur cette mission là est
ce qui vous intéresse c'est vraiment de
comprendre la population vous avez en
charge aussi de faire des photos en fait
de voir ce qu'est ce qui se passe donc
de croiser des exactions qu'est ce qui
vous a le plus marqué et comment est ce
que vous avez compris le j'avais dit à
la fin en fait il du cessez le feu et ce
conflit qui allait naître alors
arabisants par abu fans donc j'avais à
j'avais étudié l'arabe classique dix ans
avant et donc sur le terrain vous fait
feu de tout bois vous avez votre
assimilant main vous essayez de avec les
interprètes etc et puis effectivement où
je connaissais pays donc j'en avais
moins peur sans doute que certains
observateurs notamment des foules qui
avait deux qui étaient souvent très en
colère et ont les comprenez
ensuite
[Musique]
vous allez voir des personnes qui ont
été tuées oui oui vous êtes organisateur
vous êtes là pour pour prendre des
photos soulever les draps alors vous
êtes là pour constater que la paix est
maintenue quand il ya un conseil caméo
sinon vous êtes appelés sur tous les
incidents donc le métier consistait
effectivement à regarder tout ce qu'on
pouvait nous amener où ce qui arrivait
dans les morgues les massacres dans les
villages etc et idéalement son été
déterminé qui avait fait quoi et donc on
n'a jamais été capable de le faire
puisque c'est une manipulation
permanente dont on était conscient et
donc oui on était très exposée
beaucoup d'horreurs mais je dirais que
pour ce qui me concerne c'est pas
forcément le cas de certains mes
camarades qui ont fait des des
transferts sur leurs enfants sur les
corps des enfants etc moi c'est pas ça
tout à fait moi ce qui m'a beaucoup
marqué c'était les vivants pour moi les
morts étaient morts et on avait
tellement toute façon on n'allait pas
faire un deuil par personne s'cusez moi
de le dire peut être un peu abruptement
c'était l'évidence était d'abandonner
les vivants à leur sort et notamment
tous les gens dont on servait
parfaitement qu'ils allaient partir à la
torture et être et être ensuite exécuté
il y à un moment particulier dans votre
livre c'est celui où vous voyez un
prisonnier brûlé pourquoi
je vois un solde un brûlé
le yuan attentats très important contre
un poste de soldats
de l'armée syrienne l'armée régulière
des apps et des conscrits un des jeunes
donc les l'événement est très
traumatisant et l'alarmé syrien envoie
des renforts pour sortir ces gens là et
l' armée syrienne libre donc les
rebelles sur tout autour dans la zone
des combats s'engagent on réagit mal
nous l'onu alors on est on se trouve en
premier de ces combats et dans les
combats un camion prend feu et le soldat
qui le soldat qui connaît le camion
prend feu dans la cabine est en fait ce
que je raconte c'est que
je n'ai pas voulu détourner les yeux
j'ai pas voulu détourner yeux je me suis
dit comment est ce qu'on peut refuser un
regard à un homme qui meurt est-ce que
la dernière chose que je voudrais voir
si moi je sais pas si vous voyez encore
je pense pas mais est ce que la dernière
chose que j'aurais voulu voir c'est
quelqu'un qui se détournent ou bien
accompagner ce soldat dans la mort ces
questions de traumatisme vous en avait
parlé avec votre groupe vous en avez à
parler avec les larmes et aujourd'hui
avec le groupe oui je suis dans le livre
que en tout cas moi j'essaie de me
préserver parce que j'ai déjà une
expérience de toutes ces choses là et
j'ai eu déjà beaucoup de chance une fois
donc j'essaie de trouver des trucs et
des astuces pour me préserver mois et
qui fonctionne qui fonctionne pour moi
donc les gens
identifient que j'ai quelques méthodes
je leur en donne j'explique que je suis
pas médecin alors les gens qui sont trop
abîmés je peux pas faire grand chose
pour les autres j'essaie de leur donner
quelques techniques empiriquement défini
par mois
et mais c'est difficile parce que c'est
difficile d'en parler il faut déjà que
les gens l'admettent le reconnaissent
ensuite ya une phase non pas de déni
mais lorsque quelqu'un se dit pas où
j'ai un bts des mets à leur poids
maintenant j'en fais quoi donc et puis
on était dans des situations où la
douleur psychique isole et c'est toute
la différence avec l'armée française
vous avez des gens qui sont aguerris
ensemble qui s'entraînent ensemble qui
sont des frères d'âme quand un vrai une
un vrai esprit de cohésion nous on
prenait lé choc affectif d'une très
grande violence et la douleur psychique
qui vous isole complètement les uns des
autres donc c est de ce point juste
assez compliqué ensuite dans l'armée
française j'ai pas parlé de ça se paie
spécifiquement mais c'est aujourd'hui un
sujet qui est qui est très souvent
abordés dans les armées un groupe
apparaît dans votre livre ce sont des
gens qui viennent d'irak ce sont des
terroristes je parle de ça parce que
forcément leurs exactions sont aussi
particulièrement violente vous avez vu
arriver al qaïda
on a vu arriver à quetta de deux façons
différentes on s'est rendu compte que
dans damas il y avait de plus en plus
d'attentats qui demandait vraiment un
courage
exceptionnel alors on savait pas que les
gens se sacrifier mais c'était de plus
en plus osés de plus en plus c'est l
intérieur d parfois des services de
renseignement c'était très très
spectaculaire en fait c'était al-qaïda
qui arrivent et qui faisait savoir qui
faisait sa promo en gros si vous voulez
on est là on peut vous aider et puis
l'autre l'autre façon dont on s'en est
rendu compte on a on a été deux équipes
à des moments différents être une équipe
prise en otage et une autre la mienne en
embuscade et entendre sur ce genre d'al
qaïda et la première phrase que l'on
entend enfin moi je sais tout de suite
avec qui en est puisque la première
phase que l'entente parle de ben laden
le jihad international de deux coups
phare et ses bombes nous égorger
d'ailleurs et mémé d'habitude en syrie
on n'entendait pas de la révolution de
la liberté de la syrie et là on sait
tout de suite on n'est pas très bien la
frontière irakienne et on a très bien
compris qui vient d'arriver et le
s'engage une négociation irréel comme un
dossier dont vous discutez pour les
avantages et les inconvénients de nous
égorger et ce jour là on nous a relâché
une toute dernière question j'allais
dire dans toutes les guerres il ya de la
manipulation vous l'avez qu'on veut en
syrie ça vous donne aussi une lecture
sur ce qui se passe par la suite y
compris ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui en
ukraine moi je je je en tant que
militaire je suis pas tout à fait libre
de mes propos est tout à fait normal
donc je commenterai pas l'aspect
géopolitique mais c'est sûr c'est qu'il
ya un effet miroir et je retrouve
particulièrement l'aspect manipulation
mais c'est toutes les guerres comme ça
nous quand on est arrivés 300
observateurs c'est un peu l'équivalent
de ce que je vois avec les journalistes
en ukraine vous avez la communauté
internationale qui arrive qui a les yeux
qui sont là et on a littéralement fait
exploser la violence en syrie parce
qu'on est devenu un enjeu de guerre et
j'ai l'impression sont censés être moi
même et j'ai l'impression que les
journalistes qui sont en ukraine se
retrouve dans cette situation là ils
deviennent un enjeu de guerre et donc la
violence augmente parce qu'il faut
pouvoir montrer que l'ennemi est pire
que ce soit et ça ouvre la porte à tout
un tabac de manipulation de mensonges
d'exactions cet effet miroir là je pense
que je pense que l'identifiant en
ukraine mais ils ont toutes les guerres
merci beaucoup et on aura un châle pour
avoir répondu aux questions de france 24
est bonne suite de programmes sur votre
chemin
[Musique]